okay we're going to lose a major war
this is a tweet you put up everybody
loves these tweets I even have got
chimed in on them one time or another
and this is
a tweet that had been posted it says
from a friend I'm about to fail my
workplace violence prevention training
because the test was designed by high
school girls U.S Navy really striking
fear into the hearts of our enemies
these days apparently there was some
guidance given in the US Navy that a
crumpled picture is still workplace
violence we've covered on this show how
now people in the Army in the Navy have
to listen to woke videos that sound like
Sesame Street about pronouns when
instead they should be learning how to
go fight to defend well I say to defend
Freedom at this point it's to regain
Freedom frankly talk to me a little bit
about what you see as having been in the
military in active duty what does this
do to you when you see this stuff
well I I don't think we've been so
blessed in America just let me feel the
best around your own show for a second
Jedediah if you don't mind we've been so
blessed in America
militarily that we actually we think we
know what gigantic loss means like
military lawsuits and we have no idea as
a country people will remember when we
lost those 13 brave warriors in
Afghanistan and how torn up we all were
I mean I dag near choked up on the radio
that night just torn up thinking about
them
13. in Modern Warfare when you don't
have let's say
the air when you don't own air power or
you don't have the better Navy you lose
13
000 in an afternoon how about an entire
Carrier Group in America at the bottom
of the Pacific Ocean how are you going
to feel that next morning I want people
to understand the stakes before I say
what I'm about to say what you're seeing
right now is not something that's
happening in the distant future as we
speak your military the mightiest in the
world is this is being destroyed before
your eyes the Decay is huge there's two
two parts of it there's a hard Purge and
a soft Purge and the Communists are
doing this on purpose it's actually
really brilliant because the first thing
any communist country has ever done is
Purge the military of its political
opponents so we can use the military
against its political opponents the one
that have a vaccine mandate who's going
to refuse to take the vaccine Jedediah
how many Democrats in the military are
going to refuse to take the vaccine now
it's gonna be all guys on the right so
they're all kicking them out that's the
hard Purge now we have the soft Purge
and this is back to what you were just
talking about there's two parts to it
there's the guy guys who are in who
don't want to serve under this anymore
and then the guy who would join but
doesn't men type amen that uh Country
Bumpkin in Louisiana who you love to
make fun of who can go build a Hut out
of squirrel meat that guy wins your Wars
for you the high school wrestler in Iowa
wins your Wars for you all right those
guys win your Wars for you those guys
don't join a military to learn how evil
white people are every day and they
don't join the military to have a new
transsexual Lieutenant those guys join
for adventure and danger they joined for
service and camaraderie they join for a
bunch of type a male stuff they join so
they can look good for pretty girls and
hit on Jedediah Bila whenever they see
her in a bar they don't join the U.S gay
military they do not do it they will not
do it and I don't give a crap if that
offends you because it's true and the
guys who are in I'm talking about the
real pipe hitters the guys who are
warriors they're getting out I know I
have stats and stacks of emails from
them Jesse I did 12 I can't do anymore
Jesse I'm counting the minutes Jesse all
the hard-nosed guys are leaving and that
next generation of hard-nosed guys that
would be replacing them they're not
joining recruitment numbers are down 50
we're half of our recruitment numbers
for a reason my sons look you asked me
four years ago five years ago when I let
my sons join sure sure of course now not
in a million years no you go do
something else go serve somewhere else
you're not you're not going to serve
that filth and it's happening so fast
that people don't realize it and so when
I say we're going to lose a major war
I'm trying to basically slap people
awake to what that looks like you know
what that looks like right that could
look like an American city in a smoking
ruin that you don't think that can
happen that's Japan how that can happen
when they work their way to you that's
what it looks like in the end but hey
keep pushing all the lgbtq filth out
there and tell white people how much
they suck and you see what kind of a
military you have in the end it's going
to be one that's going to be good for
only one thing attacking Republicans and
that's it if you like the short clip you
can catch another one he here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]